Hey youtubers it’s charlie.
Last night in my walking dead review I asked
you all to submit questions and now it’s
time to answer them.
It’s also time to crown this week’s giveaway
winner.
So congratulations Jenna Al-Sharif.
You are the first winner.
In your comment you said you almost cried
when you thought rick was dead.
Well now you can stop crying because you just
won 20 dollars.
I’ll be messaging you on your channel for
details.
Everybody be sure to give her a high five!
Round 2 of the giveaway will be during my
episode 10 review next sunday.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get that video.
Time for some questions!
Question Number 1 - Lily Love (no avatar)
asks This episode was a pretty faithful adaptation
from the comic book.
What other storylines from the comic book
would you want to see be played out on the
show?
That’s easy, I think they should do the
Hunters this season.
It was one of my predictions, but since they’re
not always 100% faithful to the comic they
might merge some characters together.
There will be a new villain in the next couple
of episodes.
Even if it’s a twist on the comic book story
I still hope they include some of the events
surrounding that group.
Question Number 2 - Supercharged chargers
(no avatar) asks What do you think about only
seeing Rick, Michonne and Carl then the next
episode seeing only the other group?
I think it’s a good opportunity to spend
extra time on certain characters, it’s the
reason we got all that michonne and carl.
The cast is so big it’s hard to give characters
a lot of scenes without taking potential scenes
away from others.
So next week instead of Rick, Carl and Michonne.
We’ll get Maggie, Glenn and everyone else.
Crossing my fingers on Baby Judith too.
Question Number 3 - Andresm92 asks What was
that Michone's rampage?
The pain of what happened at the prison finally
got to her.
So all the awful things from her past that
she shut out of her mind just got vomited
up in a hurricane of sword slashes.
You could make the argument that just as carl
threw up after he escaped the pile of walkers.
Michonne kind of vomited up all of the feels.
Question Number 4 - Ben Roycroft asks Do you
feel that Rick will survive until the next
season or do you think he will meet his end
in the finale?
I think of the two big leaders right now,
Daryl and Rick, Rick will be the first one
to go.
I know that someone is going to die before
the end of the season.
But I think on the list of who it might be,
Rick is really low.
So I do think he’ll make it to season 5.
They’ve already deviated from the comic
in terms of characters that have died.
Question Number 5 - Guijone Halili asks Do
you think baby Judith is alive?
Yes, I do.
Mostly because what would be the reason to
not show her to us.
It’s most likely that they want us to wonder
whether or not she’s dead.
And by not having her in this episode it just
sweetens the payoff when we finally do
find out.
Question Number 6 - Monty Gonzales asks Did
Michonne know those footprints were Rick and
Carl as she followed them?
No, she just knew that they were the footprints
of people who survived.
Walkers drag their feet, so that’s how she
knew they were alive.
They were clean prints.
She was probably just hoping they belonged
to friends.
Question Number 7 - Zee Snake (no avatar)
asks Do you think Tara will become sort of
like Michonne after losing both her niece
and her girlfriend?
Do you think she'd withdraw from Lily as a
whole?
I’m actually really interested to see which
group they end up with.
They’re both alive, but no.
I think Lily is the one who will go nuts and
turn into someone like Michonne during season
3.
Just completely numb.
Tara was all talk, remember how she ended
up being a terrible shot when her girlfriend
was trying to practice with her.
Question Number 8 - Josh Bello asks Do you
think Carol will show up by the end?
She’ll show up way before the end.
Maybe not next week, but soon.
I think she’ll run into Tyreese’s group
first and there will be this cloud of weirdness
hanging over them until tyreese finds out.
I’m interested to see if he reacts the way
we expect him to, or if he surprises us and
just accepts it.
Right now, my money is on him going crazy.
Question Number 9 - Jarl Mikael asks Q&A:
Why does Michonne's two zombies never try
to attack/bite her?
She tore off their jaws, so they can’t bite.
They’re literally just pets.
They were actually two of the governors men.
Question Number 10 - The Clay Sloth (no avatar)
asks Do you think they will introduce another
antagonist like the governor?﻿
Yes, everyone is wondering if it’s going
to be Negan, but that seems too far ahead.
I think it will be the gareth character that
they cast.
He’s new this season, but I think he’ll
be an amalgam of the leader of the hunters
and negan.
Or at least a minor villain if he doesn’t
last to season 5.
and one more Bonus Question - Kevin Antihero
(no avatar) asks Will they will start following
the comic more closely?
Do you think the remaining survivors will
now head to Washington, D.C.?﻿
Just because they did in this episode, no.
It will be like before, they’ll loosely
follow the plot of the comics.
Yes I do think at least one group will make
it to washington DC.
Or at least find out about it.
The name of the finale is “A”, which everyone
is taking to mean Alexandria.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions.
Since I have some extra time this week I might
do one more walking dead video before next
sunday’s episode.
If you didn’t see I just posted a breakdown
of the new Game of Thrones foreshadowing video.
Click here for that.
And click here for all of my walking dead
predictions this year.
Thanks for watching.
See you tonight.
High fives!